we have to digitize kyogre's essence
action
i think we could do all of keanu reeves
in a day if canada is not right video
doesn't work
and i feel keanu reeves
i'm i'm such a big fan of count reviews
man like
i've loved him since speed that was an
awesome movie and of course the matrix i
mean
he's the one there's all these articles
about how nice counter reeves is keanu
gives all of his money away
keanu takes the time to hang out with
homeless people i think the world
needs more people like counter reeves
you guys remember the tom cruise video
right we had a
tom cruise impersonator come in do his
thing and we put a
tom cruise deep fake over his face right
the result
was jaw-dropping nico learned about the
technology in the tom cruise video
and i thought well how funny would it be
if counter reads stop an armed robbery
with kindness
so look if i can't work with keanu right
now i think
this is the next best thing we have to
digitize keanu's essence
so we gotta run a test we gotta see if
we can put keanu reeves face on my body
just see if it works so we're doing the
scanner he's
thing and clint's like no let's do a
real test i got a wig
i put a suit on so i did it's the
goofiest looking thing
so i mean keanu reeves how are you doing
hey
wow man
man it's very strange it looks a little
better than i thought it would like
so few iterations too you know he like
definitely like
he bends his hands like all the way back
full palm you know
and he's constantly trying to open those
pickle jars
it's like each of you smiles piano rips
you have to like suppress it you know
the wig makes it look like office meds
or something like that
like you got a loop being lost it's like
less foreign i can't wait to make this
video
you may have seen our tom cruise d-pick
video which we titled the best deep
picker on the internet it looked great
but if you look closely
you could tell it was a deep thing it
wasn't perfect but we learned a lot and
now for this keanu reeves video it's
time to put that tray into use
and make this one perfect so here's what
we're going to do lesson one
keanu reeves has long black hair so we
get to frame the entire face with just
black
but keanu reeves has a widow peak and
it's hard to find wigs that have
widow peaks that look good so we're
wearing a baseball cap those two things
alone
frame the face very nicely lesson two
we're going to light this scene
in a way that gives us flat underneath
lighting so we're not getting a lot of
shadow on the face we're not getting
really
direct solid lighting we're not getting
crisp shadows that has to be recreated
the build of the hat casts a shadow on
the face we're going to get some nice
even under lighting lesson three profile
shots the deep fake
can kind of do profile shots but the
problem is if somebody else's nose
is bigger than say your actor's nose it
can be putting on to the face well you
just have another big nose sticking out
below their nose and that's a problem
so we need to plan the scene in such a
way to never have the issue where
they're looking sideways
lesson four deep fakes are really only
128 by 128 pixels in the
screen here of 1080p that square is only
this big
the problem is you can't film any
close-ups what we're doing right now you
can't do that with a deep face it would
look really blurry but we don't worry
about that if you film it on the cell
phone
we're going to film the whole thing like
it's found footage on the cell phone and
we're gonna film it vertical so that's
gonna let us keep the face tinier in the
frame
so the last thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna teach our ai a much better
face compared to the tom cruise one i
think i trained the tom cruise space for
like 100 000 iterations meaning that
it's running a calculation over and over
and over and over and over again
and it did that a hundred thousand times
i thought that was great i thought that
was enough
turns out i was wrong we're going to
giving it a really good kian reeves data
set with a lot of different examples of
his face from a lot of different angles
and i have been training this keanu
reeves deep fake model for like 10
days straight boy is it satisfying
seeing those faces just crisp up nicely
we had a great response to the boston
dynamics video when that came out and we
wanted the same with this one we need to
strike while the iron is hot it's
important this video comes out in a
timely manner because we wait too long
all that hard work goes to waste problem
is we kind of like any perfectionists
here especially clint so i need to sit
down with the team
and we gotta talk about this we gotta
make sure it's going to look as good as
it can look but that is also gonna come
out
when it needs to come out there's a
ticking time bomb on this video
e3 was when all the keanu love came back
you're breathtaking and right now it's
the end of june we just released a
defect video about a week ago if we want
to follow suit with the success we've
had over the last two months
basically we have two to three weeks to
release the video
if you're telling me that wednesday's
the day then that's what it is
if we wait any longer there's no point
in even making the video and i think
it's a great video and we should make it
i know that by wednesday we can make it
happen and
we'll be doing the best of what we got
we've done more with less in the past
we we know it can be a success the clock
is ticking
all right wednesday it is what was that
meeting about dude film
this video or we don't film it at all we
don't have an actor
we need someone who can impersonate
counter reeves i still think there's
something to be said about
getting a look like actor and then
dubbing it after with someone who can do
the voice
that's like plan c
jake what are you working on man have i
told you about my shallow fakes
so these deep fakes are pretty sweet
right but something that
i've been doing it's called shallow
fakes
whoa now i might look like keanu reeves
right
you might be buying it but i'm taking it
to the next level by
using this piece of tape right here okay
keanu reeves is one of the nicest guys
known to the world and we've got these
wonderful wonderful patrons out there
and that made me want to go out and do
something nice for everyone in the
studio let me show you what i mean
hey nick hey just wanted to do something
nice for you
because our patrons do such nice things
for us don't knock that over
have you heard of astro gg or aoe abu
bakr
have you heard of philip oxford or uh
alan almanza
warmaster236 did he tell you to do all
this told me to do all this okay
also matt he said to clean your keyboard
for you dude
dude you're gonna quit oh my god wait
did i actually
thank you keanu hey are you peter franz
it's me keanu
it's great to meet you oh have you heard
of will robertson
our patrons yeah we're eddie aydah he's
one of our own friends too
have you heard of not a canadian spy my
favorite person on the planet actually
it looks like your phone could use a
little thank you
yeah hey ren have you heard of guerrero
jr or mitch plensky they
they do something nice for everyone in
the studio yeah let me do something nice
for you
steal my money that's real
it's it's me honey what is this piano
have you heard of glitch cube
james bailey they've got some smudges on
it looks like christian's not here
but i'm going to tell him about brian
antosik and raymond abad
because they're also two great patrons
okay what's this
okay what's that okay so so if you guys
are interested in
in supporting everything that uh they do
in this studio consider patreon it
supports all of these videos
me nice guy keanu reeves i just i gotta
go
um i gotta go got some things to do all
right
i was at my wit's end we scoured the
internet we scoured the internet for
anyone who looked like keanu reeves
i was like it has to be right if canada
was not right video doesn't work
and i failed keanu reeves i was
scrolling through facebook and i found
the only person who i know of that can
pull this off
clint just called me up and said hey i
want you to be keanu reeves and i said
okay you can try that ruben's a voice
actor he's a stunt man
he is 5 11. we'll see if it works
what's up what are you doing here look
at these habanero cracklings
we got keanu reeves here today there he
is
anyone that keanu interacts with it's
gonna change their soul
it's like jesus
generally speaking the only rules you
have to really follow is avoid doing
profile
we also want to avoid obstructions in
front of his face but as long as you can
see the camera and i can see your
eyebrows from the camera it's fine
i'm ready to freaking get the ball
rolling
action
[Music]
hour and 20 minutes we still have this
stunt hopefully clint can
push us through this the flip guys let's
rehearse
if any shot's going to like be a hard
one this is it i'm a little worried
about this because he's going to bend
over and he's going to be doing a lot of
moving like
he's got a lot of hair wiggling in his
face and i just that might be a bit of
an issue with the deep fake
i hope brett doesn't hurt himself three
two one action
all right yeah we're good good good got
it
we got it we got it yeah it's okay one
more time it was less than an hour to
finish the day
so it's monday week after the shoot and
we're finally looking at the
final edit here i think it feels pretty
good dude oh my god is that kiana reeves
he's the nicest guy dude go come on dude
come on get out of here
i thought the edit was pretty solid from
the deep fake territory here um
that's gonna be a little challenging
that hair in front of his face i'm a
little worried about so
see if there's maybe one other take
where the hair is not hanging i'm not
saying we need to
change it right now yeah i'm just saying
be aware that this one might become an
issue as well
the performance was really solid we were
thinking that we're gonna have to do adr
which is your voice replacement for the
actor down the line but he sounds
a lot like keanu on set there's no way
we can communicate effectively
you have guns pointed at each other's
hands i mean reuben he's a voice actor
he did the voice for ken in smash
brothers
ultimate bring it on you know he's got
he's got some chops so the next step
here is clint needs to lock the edit he
needs to export all the clips that are
going to have the defects on it we need
to take those image sequences
we need to extract the faces from all
them you need to check the alignment
on the faces making sure that the eyes
are exactly on the eyes the mouth is
exactly on the mouth otherwise the face
will jump around
train the algorithm now on the final
images and then export all of it
what's up what are you working on over
here i have a new mustache do you guys
notice
it's blonde so you might not but
whatever you'll take a look
we don't want to hurt bread so we have
to do this as an effect unfortunately
because it's nice to do things practical
but when brett's involved we gotta keep
him safe we've already heard him in a
previous video
didn't want to do that again we have the
background plate right here there's
still a bunch of pieces of his head that
are there
you know that would be in the background
behind the spinning head so we got to
take those out
remove brett's head from the shot and
then we added in
this shot of brett doing a little spinny
spin
[Music]
if you want to take this clip and
animate it into a music video of sorts
and then upload it um
please tweet it at me and so basically
what i did was i isolated his head
and stabilized the footage to his head
so we can take that
we can superimpose it onto the shot to
merge these two shots together i define
frames
where the faces in each shot lined up
roughly we have normal brett face right
here
and then and we're good to go
pretty simple effect actually but very
effective an effective effect
all right niko i have the final cut of
the kiana video i can export some final
frames for you
will you be able to do some stuff
overnight uh
it's been a long day clint i mean the
thing is i could keep baking it but
honestly at this point i'm like 230
000 iterations into this fake and it
looks about as good as it's going to get
this shouldn't be a concern of mine
considering all the other costs of the
studio but it costs 50 cents for every
hour
that i'm running this gpu really yeah
i've been running deep fake crunches
around the clock for two weeks now
three weeks right three times seven
times 24
times point five we've spent 250 dollars
on deep fakes
wow dude if we're not doing any keanu
baking tonight then that gives us
literally two days
to do all of it you think that's
possible we have to fix the scorpion
king tomorrow also
fix the scorpion it's a freaking fix
working i think we could do all of keanu
reeves in a day
i got it my new computer pug it
puget systems thank you nick give a
knife
oh my god i can finally render four
times faster now
it's gonna help me do this kiana deep
fake a lot faster it's gonna help us
make this deadline
my my octane renders are gonna go so
fast
let's take a look at what's in this
thing two video cards
rtx cards it is a 2080 ti
oh man dude it smells like a new car in
here
holy crap i can i can bake some deep
fakes and render
out of cinema 4d and octane at the same
exact time you guys watching this video
right now
who know anything about computers you're
probably screaming i
i plugged my hard drive into the
motherboard right
[Music]
i got my this is like my stress thing
right now because literally today's
third like midway through thursday
i only have friday to finish this video
so i
am hoping i can get all of these deep
fakes done by the end of the day
program called face swap niko turned me
onto this program
give me a little tutorial how to use it
and how to harness its power it's true
power
i'm cranking through we got 13 shots of
ruben to debate keanu reeves onto
the shots get longer and longer as the
video goes on once it's out of face swap
it has to be composited in after effects
so we're really
kind of uh crunched for time here i'm
eager to get working on the face flop
stuff i still have a big list of things
to
do which is just how things go here
sometimes it's halfway through the day
and started face swapping yet i'll get
there
i'm using my computer nico's computer to
make this deadline i'm actually training
on my computer and then i'm setting up
all the other shots on nico's computer
thank goodness to puget is saving me
some time
[Music]
2000 iterations is just what i need
why 2000 that's basically like it's
getting more crystal clear the more
iterations you have in 2000 iterations
for like a wide medium shot that's going
to be just right but for the close-up
shot 13.
dude we're gonna need like 15 000
iterations doesn't take a couple hours
but luckily niko's pre-trained this
model to the moon and back
so we'll be we're in safe hands
those are nostrils
those are huge dude i don't know why i'm
being weird yes
we're on the home stretch right now
today's friday video goes out tomorrow
i'd say we're like a little over halfway
me peter and nico are comping everything
together
sam is mixing together sound and we're
all on it we're all
having a good time isn't that right
peter yeah man
for compositing faces it's pretty easy
came up with this really cool idea
actually and peter had nothing to do
with it
all we have to do is add grain and
compression because it's iphone footage
it's garbage so we got to make him look
like garbage even though he's a very
handsome man
nico you just want to rap out 13.
um oh yeah cool all right that's nico
and then uh
so shot 13 is 32 seconds long we had to
do manual face alignments for the first
time
and it's looking pretty good chat 13. i
think i think that's pretty good
it's really weird it's like i'm
generating a new face that's not
our original actor it's not quite key on
you it's like in between but it's better
than nothing
it's better than really blurry and
obviously fake i'm just super impressed
by these programs
five and six are done we were being
daring we were said we were gonna have
all the effects on like one or two days
turns out it's happening here's seven
we're at like 85
right now super slow so once you guys
are done with that and your computers
are free after
an hour-long render then we'll we'll
knock it out i think we're going to be
able to get
a beer and a smash bros duel and
i think it's going to be one of those
fridays so
[Music]
dean watch this that leaves one more
shot
nico's working on it now waiting on me
now
this is the last thing it's going out
right now click it's ready
put it in i did it every all the files
are in
seriously everything's finished okay
so you see you can't be dead
now get up
[Music]
it's anyone that keanu interacts with
it's gonna change their soul it's like
jesus
[Music]
way
get ready to see a million copycats of
this i'm also kind of worried that like
keanu's not going to be chill with this
yeah we'll see we'll see how this goes
don't hurt me please keanu if you're
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
i'm rendering
the switch is coming out all right beer
is here the switch is in hand guys
dean we're missing you dude
[Music]
i wanna give a shout out to the face
swap devs they've been helping me learn
a lot about deep fakes and algorithms
you guys can find
face swap one of the programs we use on
github thank you so much
all right three two one
[Music]
you